I got to sit front row at the Louis
Vuitton show and um it was two people in
my seat but we made it happen uh there
was a lady there was another lady in the
seat and she was this journalist from
Beijing it was actually kind of cool I
was asking her all these like China
questions and she was just breaking it
down for me and um but yeah we were in
the same seat so we just split it up and
then next to us was supposed to be so at
first you did she shut down son and we
almost said lack yo
it's the same seat well it was I didn't
know what to do it's a long bench with a
place specifically oh yeah
but they just give the numbers so I go
and I see her sitting like close to the
end but I know my seat is the end so I
like go to sit down and usually when you
go to sit down like the person moves
over a little bit she did not budge oh
really and I was like God damn Great
Wall just bodied me bro yeah like that's
when you man spread you like show what
time yeah
she was in position and she was not
mobile like and thank God dub you know
started like truffling and she showed
her seat same thing so we just snuggled
up other people start filling in Tyra
Banks comes right this is Tyra Banks
he's America's top model this is like
fashion Sports Illustrated like as big
as a [__] absolute boss Cyrus was
right next to her so it went me her Tyra
right me and her in the same seat me and
Asian woman in the same seat entire all
these people had moved there's no room
for tyrant Tyra comes up to these young
people who are excited about fashion
this is Tyra [__] Banks Sports
Illustrated yes the whole [__] thing
goes uh hey my seat is right there uh
can you guys slide over
they didn't even acknowledge the
question was asked wow this is pyro
[__] [__] bro that's gotta feel bad
Next Level Next Level how did you
respond I was ignoring too because
I was scared she was gonna ask me to sit
down what the [__] am I supposed to do
so I didn't I didn't say anything but uh
but no and then he put her in a
different well she actually handled it
well like she wasn't she wasn't a diva
she was like okay this seems kind of
weird and then kind of just like waited
for someone to come and then they put
her right behind yeah but like it worked
out but she actually handled herself yo
I thought that she was gonna have a
meltdown yeah because like it's
disrespectful like your seat's right
there she was assigned to see and then
sitting right next was supposed to be
four seats down but he was pushed down
from his seat and so on and so just
because it's a bench everyone just
slides in they probably have like a plus
one this is Asian journalist lady she is
a boss Shorty's a boss showed up in like
a hoodie and sweats
it was she was dressed like Shifty this
is she and then and then they were like
yo she told me he's like sometimes they
give me a bag so I don't look so
homeless
like and I I started asking her [__] I
was like yo can you tell me like what's
the deal right now with like kind of she
goes yo in China right now like 90 of
people got coven I got what it was like
yo and China the whole country started
protesting the lockdown uh and gave each
other protesting and they literally they
literally got in the streets and then
the country basically and this is the
first time in a hundred years the
country has acquiesced like the people's
demands because usually it's like clap
clap but so many people are out there so
the country is like fine you got it now
it's like but weren't people vaccinated
and she goes yeah but like China's got
an ego so we only let people get the
Chinese one and
it was missing a few stitches you know
what I mean
no it's just Duck Sauce
it was nothing it was literally just
like [__] water that I don't even
think it did either she said it wasn't
working so like 90 of the people got
that [__] and uh she was quick to be
like I've been here for six months don't
worry and I was like I'm like sure I'm
American like yeah Kobe can't kill me no
more yeah he was already in medical gear
bro he was dressed like this when he
pulled it let's go he didn't even care
what time it was it was a fly
good right actually shout out Mission
they they made us Mischief gave me these
son that was a fly bro but uh but I
asked her and I was like yo can I ask
you a question like what happened to
Jack ma because you heard about that the
billionaire dude who's like went ghosts
for three months and then he came back
and whatever and this is what she said
she's like in America money buys power
so if you got money you can buy
influence you can do whatever you buy
you know uh Senators you can get
whatever you want with money she goes in
China
power controls the money so Jack had a
person in government sorry so government
controls the people the money jacket a
person in government who essentially was
his protector and that person died oh
and he didn't have a relationship with
Gigi ping like that and xinji pin was
like is this guy trying to come from my
spot uh we need to send a precedent so
it was really interesting whereas in
America it's like all right the
president's out in four years we'll put
the next one in and dump 100 million
dollars in their campaign whatever but
it's a really cool like what that's how
you know you don't give a [__] about
fashion but you're sitting front row at
the biggest fashion show in the world
[Laughter]
so take a time out for three months or
they like took him somewhere I think
that they basically like yo don't [__]
with politics at all because maybe there
were some Rumblings that he might be
interested in getting involved in
politics and they basically let you know
like there's a difference that you could
be your little billionaire if you want
yeah but you know who daddy is yeah and
your daddy's gone so you're gonna act
right yeah and not do anything to
undermine my power and maybe that three
months was my house my rules dad he
didn't said my house and my rules yeah
but kind of kind of cool right like it's
I mean it's a more logical way to
maintain power than the American way
once you get money you start coming for
me yep if you want to maintain power the
best thing to do is I'm gonna let you
have your money you're gonna shut the
[__] up yep and clip it before you they
get in the position where they can take
you out yeah yeah and then she said a
wild thing then we get back to the
fashion but she was like how like what
is that thing called Alibaba yeah so
what she said about how Alibaba works is
like Alibaba is kind of almost like
their Amazon if you will basically
connects like consumers with uh the
people who have the goods to sell a lot
of times they're like factories right
but she's like what Alibaba really is is
just this place to hold the money so in
other words when you pay for something
that money doesn't get released to the
person who's making it the factory until
you get your product so at any point in
time Alibaba is holding like an entire
First World countries uh like yearly uh
was it GDP yeah at any point in time so
that type of influence you have when
you're holding that kind of money and
then you can invest that money in
different places you're basically a
gigantic country yeah and that's why I
think Jack ma was one of the people who
was you know higher up in Alibaba
Creator so that's why Gigi ping or
whatever had to be like listen you need
to know who who you work for yeah okay
it was kind of cool like talking to
someone who's actually from there
because everything that we get on you
know in the west is so biased yeah like
I didn't even know that there were
millions of Chinese people protesting
the lockdowns did y'all see that oh you
did hear okay but little things though
considering like how disproportionate
the [__] protests were this is like
millions of people protest if there's a
protest of any of that size and any like
we heard about the [__] France
protest non-stop yeah yeah and I was
like we've heard about the Iran Fortress
Non-Stop and I felt like the coverage on
China was minimal despite the fact that
it seems like in the news they like to
play up the fact that we're beefing with
China yeah so now I'm skeptical of the
beef with China
yeah or there's Chinese money going to
these corporations we don't know about
like if they own part of Reddit they own
[__] Tick Tock like yeah you're not
gonna get these things popping up the
same rate because I actually feel like
we kissed China's ass a lot on a
political level that [__] made me feel
like we really do like I don't read it
as we have beef with China I read it as
we are threatened by China and we're
cozying up to them in a way that doesn't
feel American for lack of a better way
yeah just not realizing this [__] no no
like I guess what I'm saying is usually
you take advantage of these modes for
example we're beefing with Iran right so
when there's unrest in Iran we put the
gas on it right like yeah and I'm I'm
like why are we putting the gas on the
fact that China is you can't piss off
Daddy Chinese
once you start being a WTF or whatever
they knocked a thousand dollars off of
rent and this [__] is bowing and
[__]
bro come on you really are John Cena bro
okay yeah
all day what's up